يتم تدمير غزة أمام أعين
العالم بينما تطلق إسرائيل العنان لقوتها
العسكرية الكاملة على
السكان العزل، حيث قتل أو جرح أكثر من 20 ألف طفل وامرأة
ورجل،
وتشرد مئات الآلاف من الفلسطينيين، وتحول
عدد لا يحصى من المنازل والمستشفيات
والمدارس إلى أنقاض.
جميع السكان محرومون من
أبسط حقوق الإنسان من قبل
الحكومة الإسرائيلية مع عدم إمكانية الحصول
على الماء والغذاء والدواء والكهرباء.
رسالتنا إلى الحكومة الإسرائيلية
واضحة وبسيطة، توقفوا، أوقفوا
قصف غزة، أوقفوا حصار غزة،
أوقفوا الاحتلال.  المستوطنات غير القانونية
والفصل العنصري،
يجب على المجتمع الدولي أن يكثف جهوده ويجب أن
يدعو إلى وقف فوري كامل لإطلاق النار، ويجب أن
تركز جميع الجهود على الحوار بشأن وقف إطلاق النار
وعملية تفاوض
يمكن أن تحقق خطوات عادلة ودائمة في
الشرق الأوسط، تقوم على
إنشاء دولة قابلة للحياة.  الدولة الفلسطينية